we need one dog team for a road sweep
and surrounding area check baby target I
just don't know why you want to do this
use the heat huh
you don't really connect with people
very well
just so you know running away isn't
gonna solve anything
hey note down your shirt
[Music]
found something good boy
I mean watching this dog all here it's
the most aggressive dog I've ever
treated has really needed another break
so he hasn't earned it
you're getting a dog you got this big
faster yeah I got this you think I'm
afraid of you lay down
Rex lay down vehicle approaching guns up
[Music]
why'd you join to get away from my life
shipping out tomorrow we are so not
ready for this
Claire baby check that vehicle where's
my dog
you cannot come back to my house like
some big warm here ask off mom you can't
let your whole life fall apart over some
dog that dog saved my life
please just change his classification so
that I can adopt him when he gets back
they aren't pets they're warriors
senators can I just have a moment of
your time please Rex save thousands of
lives in Iraq what do you say your name
was
purple mega media
all you do is fight be not afraid about
your marine
[Music]
what would you say to Rex if he were
here I'd think I'm for teaching me what
love is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you